[Music]
in chapters three and four of her novel
a wizard of earth see
the action is all taking place on the
isle of roke which turns out to be an
incredibly important place in the
narrative world of earth sea not only
because it's where you have the school
of wizards and mages it's an island
that's protected in many ways but also
because of the imminent grove whose
roots the the trees of which those roots
go down to the bottom
of the earth and
it is a really truly magical place pun
intended there it's a place where magic
is not just concentrated but being
taught and ideally
its graduates come out not just with a
whole set of skills but also with at
least a modicum of wisdom
and goodness although that often is not
the case as we will see in the
narratives roque is first mentioned by
the mage ogian
who is uh ged's you know teacher at gant
living at rayalbi who then says this is
where they teach all of the high arts
now that implies that there's
distinctions within magic at least from
the rokian perspective between the low
arts and that does indeed get mentioned
the arts practiced by those who don't
walk with a staff those who don't have a
wizard's staff the things that the local
sorcerer or witch or warlock might be
doing
and then the things that genuine wizards
taught at rogue know
how to do
so
gen gets sent off there with a
recommendation by ogio and this guy's
really got something on the ball he
could be the greatest you got to take
care of him
it's located on
well the school for wizards is located
in the the town of twill which surrounds
it and then the school is inside of it
and there's kind of a you know a
non
non-antagonistic
county
versus college kind of dynamic going on
there if you're not familiar with that
this is something that you see in
college towns where there are those who
are working at the college or are
studying at the college and they live at
the college but may also spend some time
out in the town and then the town is
there to handle all the things that are
needed in order to have a college all
the economic
matters such as bringing in food growing
food
all the other things that have to be
imported and exported there's a port
there at twill as well and the people
enjoy themselves it's kind of an honor
to be there there's actually a really
great description provided
of twill
in this that is is quite interesting
they went into the town that ged might
learn his way about it few and short as
were the streets of twil they twisted
and turned curiously among the high
roofed houses and the way was easy to
lose it was a strange town strange also
its people fishermen and workmen and
artisans like any other
but so used to the sorcery that is ever
at play on the isle of the wise that
they seemed half sorcerers themselves
they talked as get learned in riddles
and not one of them would blink to see a
boy turn into a fish or a house fly up
into this the air but knowing it for a
school boy prank would go on cobbling
shoes or cutting up mutton
unconcerned and so there's this you know
kind of
magical town surrounding it magical not
in the sense that everybody's using
magic but they're used to it right it's
not something that's going to blow their
minds
within the town of twill
there's an entrance
a door to the school of rogue and
there's this very nice uh
passage here
so
gad asked the first townman of twill
where he would find the water of the
school on rock the man looked at him
side long a while and said the wise
don't need to ask the fool asks in vain
one of those enigmatic responses and so
went on along the street he went uphill
till he came out into a square rimmed on
three sides but the houses with their
sharp slate roofs and on the fourth by
the wall of a great building whose few
small windows were higher than the
chimney tops of the houses a fort or a
castle it seemed made of mighty gray
blocks of stone
in the square beneath it market booths
were set up and there was some coming
and going of people
getty asked his question of an old woman
with a basket of muscles and she said
you cannot always find the water where
he is but sometimes you can find him
where he is not
and went on crying her muscles to sell
in the great building near one corner
there was a mean little door of wood
gad went to this and knocked loud
to the old man who opened the door he
said i bear a letter from the mage ogie
and i've gone to the water of the school
on this island i want to find the waters
but i will not hear more riddles and
scoffing
this is the school the old man said
mildly i am the door keeper enter if you
can
get stepped forward it seemed to him he
passed through the doorway yet he stood
outside on the pavement where he had
stood before so there's magic with this
door man more magic as we're going to
find out in just a moment
every time god steps through it he winds
up back in the same place
so obviously something's got to give
here and what it is is ged
has to give his true name to the door
keeper and this is a big thing you know
giving your true name gives people power
over you so this is a
trusting at a very basic level of ged
with this this school and once he does
enter
he says
he saw as he turned that the doorway
through which he came was not plain wood
but ivory without joint or seam it was
cut as he knew later from a tooth of the
great dragon
the door that the old man closed behind
him was of polished horn through which
the daylight shone dimly and on its
inner face was carved the thousand leave
tree welcome to this house lad the
doorkeeper said and without saying more
let him through halls and quarters to an
open court far inside the walls of the
building and here he's introduced to the
ark mage nirmalay who is the warder of
the school the arc mage is the
you know the the greatest among equals
of the
the masters of rogue who gets to decide
policy but does so in a collaborative
way the archmage by the way who will
save
ged's life when ged makes a terrible
mistake
so now we should move on to the
nine masters of rogue
and then the tenth of course is the the
arc mage who is often selected from
outside of the masters themselves
and
each of these is you could say the
best proficienter
and practitioner
of some high art something that is
really essential
to what a wizard ought to have to be a
genuine mage it's sort of like the
difference between a cook and a chef
right
there's
much more that needs to be
learned including the formation of one's
character and one's relation to one's
craft and these these masters are the
master chanter master win key master
hand the master namer the master herbal
master changer master summoner master
patterner and then finally as we find
out who's the the ninth master
the door keeper that is a
position
of mastery which will be quite important
in in later works not so much in this
book itself
so we find out
that
first what ged has to do
is spend time with the
master chanter and in doing so
he is going to be learning and what is
what is he learning there he says part
of each day
he studied with a master chanter
learning the deeds of heroes the lays of
wisdom beginning with the oldest of all
songs the creation
of ayah
so it's it's learning the basis of
things this will come up later on the
chanter is going to chant as they are
engaged in important ceremonies then we
have the master wind key
arts of wind and weather they practiced
with light cat boats steering by words
stealing waves speaking to the world's
wind and raising up the mage wind these
are very intricate skills and frequently
geds had got whacked by the swinging
boom
there were quieter expeditions ashore he
said as well and and we're going to talk
about this um
so
the
wind key why is this so important they
live in a in an archipelago of islands
if you want to get anywhere from rogue
you have to sail there and so
those who can master the weather are
incredibly
important
for the inhabitants of earth sea and
this is something that a mage
needs to know i'll mention as well that
odeon as we learn
still the earthquake so it's not just
mastering the you know the clouds the
rain the wind but also other elements
that can be important then we have
master hand
master hand is teaching
juggling and sleight of hand
but also illusion and here is where ged
has one of his first important
conversations he says to master hand
you know i
i like these illusions it's cool to turn
a pebble into a diamond but it doesn't
really turn it into a diamond so
how do i do that and master hand says oh
well that's a different kind of magic
you got to be real careful with that son
he also
spends time with the master herbal
we find out that
master herbal who taught the ways and
properties of things that grow this is
something that ged has learned to some
degree from ogen before
and perhaps even from his aunt but now
he's learning it in a much more complex
systematic
way
then we get to
a different kind of master the master
namer in the isolate tower and it's no
fun to hang out there because what
you're doing is learning long
lists of names and copying them out and
memorizing them but this is incredibly
important for
a wizard because knowing the names of
things is what allows you to cast spells
and to control them to to
that if you can't control them at least
cajole them into doing something like
what you want or to ward them off and so
they spend a lot of time doing that get
again asks about things and finds out
that
the names of things are absolutely
important i'm going to read this passage
in the world under the sun and in the
other world that has no sun there is
much that has nothing to do with men and
men's speech and there are powers beyond
our magic but magic true magic
is worked only by those beings who speak
the heartic tongue of earthsea or the
old speech from which it grew that is
the language dragons speak into the
language segoy spoke who made the
islands of the world and the language of
our ladies songs spells enchantments and
invocations so
not knowing the
the language would put you at a
disadvantage and you have to learn this
thing again at first doesn't like being
there after his terrible incident with
the shadow
he's happy to be there because
everything is so quiet
then we find out
that
they study
with
some of the
other people here we go
ken stayed in the great house working
with the masters at all the skills
practiced by sorcerers those who work
magic but carry no staff they're not
wizards or mages
windbringing weather working finding and
binding the arts of smell spellsmiths
and spell
rights tellers chanters helals and
herbalists so he's also spending more
time with the master herbal and with the
master wind key and some of the others
as well finding by the way was at one
time the mastery of one of the people at
rogue but as we find out in a later book
then we get introduced to two more
the master changer
and the master summoner
and with these two as with the master
namer
we're getting away from things that if
they're not low arts or at least like
middle level arts you know
chanting
weather working
illusions
knowing herbs and and other things of
that sort
we're getting to those who manipulate
reality
itself
and so first we see the master changer
we find out gad was 15 very young to
learn any of the high arts of wizard or
mage those who carry the staff but he
was so quick to learn all the arts of
illusion that the master changer himself
a young man soon began to teach him
apart from the others and to tell him
about the true spells of shaping
he explained how if a thing is really to
be changed into another thing it must be
renamed for as long as the spell lasts
and he told how this affects the names
and natures of things surrounding the
transformed things he told of the perils
of changing and little by little the
young master began to do more than
merely tell him of these mysteries he
taught him first one that another of the
great spells of change and he gave him
the book of shaping to study this he did
without knowledge of the archmage and
unwisely yet he meant no harm so get his
learning stuff that he should learn
later on
but he is he is learning it and he's
learning it kind of at a intermediate to
master level
then we get to the master summoner the
master summoners we found was a dour old
man who won't tell ged some of the stuff
that kid wants to know about but the
master summoner
he deals with no illusion only true
magic the summoning of energies as light
and heat and the force that draws the
magnet and those forces men perceive as
weight form color sound
real powers drawn from the immense
fathomless energies of the universe
which no man spells or uses could
exhaust or unbalance so and he also
helps them to understand the meaning the
deeper meaning of these other things so
the master win key right the weather
workers and sea masters calling on wind
and water were crafts already known to
his pupils
it was he who showed them why the true
wizard uses such spells only at need
since to summon up such earthly forces
is to change the earth of which they are
apart
as for the calling of real things and
living people the raising up of spirits
of the dead and the invocations of the
unseen the spells that are the height of
the summoner's art and the mages power
he those he scarcely spoke of to them
ged tries to get him to talk about it
but he's he's not cool with that at this
point with his students and
it's at this point where ged actually
uses a spell
in in rivalry with another
young student jasper who's several years
ahead of him who's been riding him the
entire time
he uses a spell that opens up a
path
for unlife to come in this monster that
ends up
having to be fought off by the arc mage
and some of the other masters ged
himself his studies are interrupted as
his body and spirit are damaged and have
to heal
he goes back again after that to the
master namer in the isolate tower to
renew his studies and then he comes to
the master patterner
and we find that the master patterner
is
a different
type of person he doesn't actually
teach
instead he
he
has him spend time
in the imminent grove here we go the arc
mage sent get after his 18th birthday to
work with the master patterner
what is learned in the imminent grove is
not much talked about elsewhere it is
said no spells are worked there and yet
the place itself is an enchantment
sometimes the trees of that grove are
seen and sometimes they are not seen and
they are not always in the same place
and part of roque island
it is said that the trees of the grove
themselves are wise it is said that the
master patterner learns his supreme
magery there within the grove and if
ever the trees should die so shall his
wisdom die and in those days the waters
will rise and drown the islands of earth
see which segoy raised from the deeps in
the time before a myth before all the
all the lands where men and dragons tell
but this is all hearsay wizards will not
speak of it and so what is god learning
there what's being evoked in this story
some sort of wisdom
but it's one that is being
learned from the grove and its trees
itself that are enchantment
finally we find out that the master door
keeper is
one of the masters
and
how does ged get out he
uh
is told that he has to
come up with the
the name the true name of the doorkeeper
and ged isn't able to actually
do that until he finally asks him he
says master i cannot take your name from
you not being strong enough and i cannot
trick your name from you not being wise
enough so i'm content to stay here and
learn or serve whatever you will
meaning that the door keeper can teach
him something unless by chance he will
answer a question i have asked it what
is your name the doorkeeper smiled and
said his name ged repeating it entered
for the last time into
that house
so
we have the masters of roke we have a
school of magic very powerful with long
traditions a systematic approach to
things
but definitely not the only
mode
or
type or even tradition
of magic within earthsea and we learn
this
by ged himself traversing
this curriculum which we'll learn more
about in later books but it's enough for
a wizard of earthy to get our first
glimpse of what they're teaching what
they consider to be
important for a wizard or a mage to have
learned
you